what's in your view is the difference
gene our perception like how we think
the world is and reality do you think
there's a huge gap there like we delude
ourselves as the whole thing is an
illusion just everything about human
psychology the way we see things and how
things actually are all the things
you've studied what's your sense how big
is the gap between reality well so again
purely speculative I think that we will
never know the answer we cannot know the
answer there is no experiment to find an
answer to that question everything we
experience is an event in our brain when
I look at a cat I'm not even I can't
prove that there's a cat there all I am
experiencing is the perception of a cat
inside my own brain I am only a witness
to the events of my mind I think it is
very useful to infer that if I witness
the event of cat in my head it's because
I'm looking at a cat that is literally
there and it has its own feelings and
motivations and should be pet and given
food and water in love I think that's
the way you should live your life but
whether or not we live in a simulation
I'm a brain-in-a-vat I don't know and do
care mmm I don't really well I care
because it's a fascinating question and
it's a fantastic way to get people
excited about all kinds of topics
physics psychology consciousness
philosophy but at the end of the day
what would the difference be if you the
cat needs to be fed at the end of the
day otherwise would be a dead cat right
but if it's not even a real cat then
it's just like a video game cat and
right so what's the difference between
killing a a digital cat in a video game
because of neglect versus a real cat it
seems very different to us
psychologically like I don't really feel
bad about oh my gosh I forgot to feed my
Tamagotchi right but I would feel
terrible if I forgot to feed my actual
cats
you